[Music]
what's going on guys the live-action
Beauty and the Beast hits theaters March
17 so we here at screen junkies set out
with the simple task of determining the
best Disney Princess ever I know right
but we're going to figure that out today
and we've got a pretty cool panel of
Disney fans to talk about it with first
she's one of the hosts of Disney
inspired YouTube channel singham of
loggs
and she's a self-professed pretentious
Disney fan Sara sterling Sara thanks for
being here thanks for having me and he
is also a host on thingamavlogs you
might have seen him as Prince Eric
online and he's one of the hosts on game
talk Leo Camacho thanks for being here
know anything about me and you know this
guy he's the curator of New York Times
best-selling graphic novel love is love
and the author of Batman 66 verse Wonder
Woman 77 mark and Rico good to see you
again so for the purposes of these
rankings we are using the 11 Canon
Disney Princesses plus Moana and Elsa
come on they deserve it
1301 leaves yes oh man I'd love to see
like a bloodsport about royal okay each
of these 13 Disney princesses were
judged in seven categories categories
are royal lineage quality of sidekick
independence singing / theme song
intelligence relatability and talent we
receive the votes from our judges we
tallied them and the results are in
buckle up this is going to be quite a
ride coming in at the bottom the lowest
ranked Disney Princess according to you
three Aurora from Sleeping Beauty Wow
makes sense mark you had her extremely
low rated yeah I gave her straight zeros
with the exception of royal lineage I
think you brought down the total court
yet it was not my lowest rank yeah we'll
do any Trisha mr. finger and sleeps
until a guy kisses her in true but in
the categories of sidekick and singing
she ranks pretty high for me Oh what
does she say what's her signature to
once upon a dream is a Disney classic
she has a great voice
I am quarter pretty low generally as
well but I gave her a pretty decent
score for Royal any
it's because the reasons you've even
banished to the forest if we could she's
part of a royal lineage the Melissa
--scent is really pissed about Wow and
who is her sidekick her sidekicks are
the theories for her sidekick is that
glass bed Sleeping Beauty is taking a
dirt nap because she's last on our list
yeah
oh man a classic she's ranked 12th by
you guys Snow White
why so low on Snow White we Oh what did
she do she runs away from her troubles
because a cottage in the middle of the
forest was not mean nothing it doesn't
even run away she gets chased away
she doesn't decide to run exactly she's
gonna skate and murder and then he
really helps the cause of little people
and those little people are the only
high score you know got a good psychic
organ site if it weren't for them she'd
be home 13 for a sign not great for a
sign yeah her intelligence rating is low
because like oh yeah what's one of the
dumbest things she does you know cut an
apple it goes into a stranger's house
and just gets in a bed and falls asleep
she orgy party I gave her a low talent
girl so cuz what'd she do she makes a
few Queens she cleans I wash no sweetie
there's going to be no Cinderella story
today because Cinderella came in at
number eleven Wow the first three bottom
three yeah
wow that's shocking the first three that
that is insane
they're the bottom three so what do we
attribute that to well they were getting
the hang of how to create characters
yeah you know email character
development in mainstream media wasn't
really a thing that's it that's an
excellent thought leo the portrayal of
women in Disney movies and these
animated characters has evolved over
time but I did find her fairly
independent and I did find her fairly
you know fairly intelligent there was a
relatability because we well whether you
have evil stepsisters or you have a big
brother that gave your noogies when you
were a kid that sort of sibling dynamic
is relatable I really take on back to
that point in my childhood mark what was
the highest category you have for
Cinderella Sarah um I never even Lee for
a sidekick steampunk and intelligence oh
it's a fun sidekick so is my knight I
hope to make her dress the first time
the dog Bruno no coming in next Elsa
from frozen coming in at number ten Wow
so uh should have been worse should have
been the worst says Marvin Draco how did
you rate her Sarah i raided her really
low with
sidekick and intelligence and
relatability and very high for a theme
song because let it go is the most
iconic newest Disney I balanced rock
because I gave it a zero because that's
the worrying song ever it felt like it
was grown in the lab and it should be
called anthem
I mean it's catchy though I don't think
you can it you can hate it you can love
it but it is a phenomenon it's like my
whole life got turned upside down I gave
her a high score on talent you ever
found what's amazing I got the castle
out of I even loved one because in the
superpower Elsa is frozen out of the
number one spot up next coming in at
number nine Merida from brave not
exactly the most popular Disney Princess
film of all time
Leo talk to me about your scores from
Merida what what's something you rated
are high she got a high score on talent
she's actually my second highest rated
in talent oh wow because her archery
skills are through the roof she actually
beats out the neighboring countries in
archery whoa yeah she's very talented
Sarah any thoughts on Merida good bad
otherwise I rated her high in
Independence because she her whole story
arc is about doing what she wants
following her past rated her extremely
low on singing and bam song because
there's not a music being shown have a
song well there I thought on that
question it right now there's a song in
the movie but she's doing it she's a
talented Archer but she's not hitting
the bull's eye today ladies and
gentlemen okay coming in at number eight
and I remember I argued on a movie
fights for this being my favorite Disney
Princess of all time but she's only
coming in number eight Mulan Mulan I
thought yeah I'm waiting area she's not
I give her give her a zero for where
lineage she's not a princess I gave her
home her off so she got great scores in
quality of sidekick because mu she was
actually really funny independent she
defies her family to go hell yeah the
theme song is pretty great even though
Donny Osmond's enrolled in it well is
reflection the theme song or Islamic
Amana to you the theme song okay Arlene
are you levels are great well the great
song exactly the never movies is really
underrated so she got really high scores
for me all across the board with the
exception of the royal lineage part in
census was about princesses it's
important that she rules and on rags are
down yeah I'm
surprised because I feel like we already
to her a very high except for Royal I
went she was middle which I'm really
yeah
Milan falls by the wayside coming in at
number seven oh let down your hair for a
Rapunzel leo how'd you rate her Rapunzel
in talent number one she's got a
thousand town yeah her life is
developing talent Wow hair no no that
was a comment about all the dresses yes
I am the usual morning light is like
chess and painting and sewing Sarah want
to talk to you you had Rapunzel tied for
your second highest rated princess tell
me what what you like about Rapunzel I
think I rated her very high for sidekick
because I love Pascal and he actually
saves the day at the end of the movie so
like one of the best I've sidekicks on
this list for sure kill the villain
kills the villain weather alert boy we
haven't seen it yeah I read are very
high on talent Irene here pretty high on
singing also I see the lights of grace
on lowest and independence though long
low she stays locked in that tower
number 7 on our list coming in at number
six from Princess and the Frog
Tiana now mark you had Tiana ranked
pretty high tell me about some of your
scores on Tiana independent she's one of
them one of the really aggressively
independent ones it doesn't she was a
reaction to a lot of the complaints
about Disney Princesses
it feels very timeless in spite of that
being based on the zeitgeist of the time
Leo tell me about Tiana sidekick you
know i rated it low because i wasn't I
forgot about the Firefly and he's one of
the most emotionally interesting side
cakes of all time haven't you forget
about the how dare I
what's Tiana signature song I would say
it's almost there which is a great song
i braided her very high for some yeah
that backs up your no absolutely
absolutely I think I think Princess and
the Frog is one of the most underrated
of these movies on this list and it
people need to revisit it well too bad
Tiana couldn't leapfrog the five other
princesses in front of her we are
hitting the top five processes of all
time coming in at number five from
Aladdin jasmine so mark you had jasmine
rated off the charts talk to me honey
jasmine is a great character
usually when though when there's a lead
in the movie the love interest is just
kind of there is a
and this Jasmine is arguably a more
interesting character than Aladdin
because she is so progressive in such a
vibrant real character she's an equal to
the lead I hear you on that but you know
who doesn't hear you on that
leo who raided jasmine very low leo go
ahead and cheat on jasmine yeah let me
take a big old dump on dad ha ha ha I
had her huge really polarizing to me she
got the highest in royal lineage because
it's a long line of the Sultan and the
palace is huge and all that but in
talent she got the lowest score for me
because she's just the princess who
doesn't have to do anything for herself
when she finally does get at it she
tries to have independence so I ranked
her low there because she gets out she
sneaks out of a camp yeah and I can't do
any of it is that capable of taking care
of it I didn't even know in her own City
that she'll lose her hands big man
doesn't know how to pay for any her
sidekick though is great Raja
yeah Haider it kills people let's talk
about her iconic song well I would say a
whole new world isn't even her song
writing about her and Aladdin showing
her a whole new world on his magic
carpet it's arguable that a whole new
world is allowed in song she's such a
vibrant care cause it feels like a duet
even though it's technically not she
overpowered that song for sure
it wouldn't be the same song about her
no absolutely not I guess she didn't rub
the lamp the right way because she's not
moving on to number one the live-action
version is coming our way but Belle from
Beauty and the Beast coming in number
four Marc she might have been your
highest rated yeah I gave her a zero for
lineage and everything else top scores
Wow Sarah you had a more pedestrian
scores for Belle
he's the thing those one of my favorite
princesses I have some huge problems
with her but I'll lay it on us I think
she's very pretentious
and I call myself four dentists but
she's in her opening song as her just
being like look at all these fools
they're just peasants none of them know
how to read and she likes to read
there's nothing pretentious when
everyone around you is an idiot I agree
that they are idiots when guest on is
your high standard
yes I've got some attached you're within
a really bad town I gave her the best
sidekick score but here's the thing I
realized you guys probably reading her -
sidekicks for the intended objects yeah
those are my first I cake so to the
beasts idea but any Gompers now they're
not the leaves I kick to the beasts
employee yeah humberto by the way who
died here around her they're forced to
be with I didn't even know it was a
controversial hot cakes today talk to me
about Belle's song they're all
everything she sings is
yeah no I read her very high for song
and singing leo would you rate her
lowest on lowest was on talent and royal
lineage yeah yeah she's not now she can
read that's not a talent Belle did not
go beast mode today she falls at number
four we got to leave we happy listen if
you're allergic to puns this is the
wrong place to be today
Thank You number three Pocahontas polka
pretty high scores except from leo leo
you had our fruit you know fairly
pedestrian scores for profile
she's middle of the road I guess middle
of the road yeah I don't feel like she
stands out particularly in any one area
but she's you know efficient all of them
well then she's probably been she's a
daughter of a chief and he's probably
the son of another chief and so on and
so forth that's pretty good you had her
rated pretty high Sarah talk to me about
what you like about Pocahontas
I think her sidekicks are great play and
Miko are great alternative if you want
to count and call girl love the constant
want to talk about that publicly hi
royal lineage by an independent she
basically lives her life the way that
she wants to live it it does she's got a
talent though she jumps off a cliff with
perfect form no splash I fell pretty
middle Talent
she's got some killer song look what's
your iconic song color was Allah where's
the wind yeah favorite isn't on the
motel
no reason just run the river oh man just
like her beautiful Swan dives she will
not make a splash in today's competition
because she falls in at number three you
guys we're down to the top two does it
get more exciting I don't think so the
number two Disney Princess The Little
Mermaid Ariel emo why met so Marc Ariel
is your highest rated by far yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely royal lineage she
has multiple great sidekicks she's
independent she has great theme songs
the intelligence is arguable but she's
always wanting to learn besides her name
on a form to get legs then can't convey
that to the Prince to tell him her name
or what the situation was yes you can
write it wrote her name Ariel you
could've written in the sand so yeah Leo
you had Ariel rated you know fairly
pedestrian scores yeah tell
about your ring well obviously royal
image look you were saying is to leave
their sidekick Sebastian is one of the
best sidekick CGI things in line
Sebastian is definitely the stronger
side kick and then flounder and then
scuttle who's absolutely is love you yes
but flounder is great though because
flounder being so nice and so naive
allows Sebastian to be a little saucy
err the flounder wasn't there Sebastian
might come off a little mean yeah great
plan
yeah they balance each other but she's a
dummy she can't convey a story without
without her voice which is make sure
worthless basically and talent what did
she do she flops around that's not
talent but she's number one of my things
theme songs yeah that seems on of all
the data's Wow
are you learning your world she's not
going to be part of our world anymore is
she that she's not number one and other
mccollum grabby okay
ladies and gentlemen the number one
Disney Princess of all time Moana Lana
Wow
so Sarah you had Moana scores off the
chart
talk to me about why you love Milano
royal lineage is high yeah she's not
over teeth same situation she's going to
be keep herself extremely independent
her theme song is a new classic how far
I'll go is great and elite koalas voice
is incredible
I find her extremely relatable and very
talented wayfinding when you know there
are no more we find it's true it's true
I gave her a low quality of psychic
because hey hey hey hey do you have
anything relatability number one for me
intelligence she's pretty bright I gave
her a high intelligence because yes he
realizes that the island is in trouble
and no one will listen to her sure don't
get me wrong I put her very high on my
list but I just think putting her at
number one I don't think she I don't
think she or the movie has earned it yet
I don't care how new she is yeah you
make a good Christmas to make a good
good bugs there you go
one is the best she's the princess of
Ariel wishes she was the girl gonna take
charge of her destiny and actually
accomplished something Wow yeah she
makes the number one Disney princess of
all time what do you think of our list
what do you think of our scores and who
in your mind is the greatest Disney
princess of all time tell us in the
comments section we want to know and
I've got to thank my awesome guest Sarah
Stirling Leo Camacho check them both out
on thingamavlogs and Mark and Draco
always great to see if Thanks
my pleasure thanks for having me thank
you for watching I'm how run next hit me
up on Twitter by like hey guys did you
know that this end card works with your
phone now I know right click the boxes
below to watch more screen junkies
videos and click the screen junkies logo
to subscribe and get this show
honest trailers movie fights and more